OK.
Hopefully your SavedGifsViewsController
is ready to go.
Now let's add the ability
to manage a collection.
If we look in the Objective C project,
we can see that
the SavedGifsViewsController conforms to
the UICollectionViewDelegate,
the CollectionViewDataSource, and
the UICollectionViewDelegateFlowLayout.
So when I add all three of
those to the Swift file.
Now let's take a look
at the implementation.
If we scroll down to where
the datasource methods are,
we can see our familiar friends.
NumberOfItemsInSection and
cellForItemAtIndexPath.
Cool, no surprises there.
Let's switch back to the swift project,
add our protocols and
then implement those methods.
I've got a mark here for
the delegate and data source methods.
And now we want to add collectionView,
numberOfItemsInSection, and
cellForItemsAtIndexPath.
For numberOfItemsInSection,
we're just going to want to
return the number of saved gifts.
And oops we're not really ready to
implement self into the next path yet
because we haven't made our custom cell.
So let's make our custom cell.
Go ahead and add the GifCell class and
have it inherit from CollectionViewCell.
Open up storyboard and
find the scene called my collection.
Inside the collection view,
you'll see the GifCell now go ahead and
drag an outlet from the GIF image
view into the GifCell class.
And then also in the GifCell class
we're going to need a function
called configureForGif and
this is where we'll set the GIF image.
And now let's switch back to
the saved GIF view controller.
And of course if we want to
be able to see our GifCell,
we should give it a size.
So let's go here to our mark for
the CollectionViewFlowLayout and
here we are.
Here's the method for
sizeForItemAtIndexPath.
So the width of our cell is going to
be approximately half the width of
the collectionView.frame.
But of course this method
expects us to return a size and
we're going to need a margin as well.
So let's go up to
the top of our class and
create a constant to hold the margin.
You'll want to make this
cell margin a CgFloat so
that it plays nicely with the CgSize and
we incorporate it into our widths.
And then, of course,
we'll want to return the size,
and we should be good to go.
So this ought to give us two columns
of cells in our collectionView.
And let's not forget to implement
cellForItemAtIndexPath.
So of course we want to dequeue a cell
we want to cast it to a GifCell.
We'll grab a gif from
the savedGifs array and
we'll figure the cell for that gif.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now sometimes when I just want to see my
cells before I have data a put in them
I'll make them a weird color so
they stand out.
So I just went into storyboard and
I made them this blue color.
And just for testing purposes,
I'm returning 5 here in
number OfItemsInSection,
and then I commented out these two
lines in cell for item index path.
And then when I run the app what I see
is this so I can see my collectionView
and I can see my cells and I can tell
that their space the way I want them.
I can also see that this view is
kind of blocking my collection.
If you look in the Objective C project.
You'll notice that this view that has
the pink squares is called the empty
view, because it's the view that's meant
to appear when the collection is empty.
My collection isn't empty right now.
So I'm going to go ahead and
add an outlet for
this empty view and
I'll add a line to viewWillAppear so
that when the number of savedGifs does
not equal zero the emptyView is hidden.
Go ahead and add an outlet to
storyboard for the collectionView and
then while we're here and
viewWillAppear we can call reload data.
And now you can move on to work
on the preview controller.